don't push me cause I'm close to the it
I'm trying not to lose my hey already we
were oh sorry
action hey I'm Martin Lawrence and I'm
Will Smith and this is do you even know
me
from uni uni lad alright will is
bilingual alright what languages can he
speak well I heard him in Mexico City is
a yep there you go
me putting a of women's a better las
películas en el centro de Philadelphia
the run team ever Cascione de Navidad
where was martin born and raised DC
Virginia New York boy raised you were
raised a decent range in raising DC is a
it's a oh it's too far so the raised
part your run raised fry you're raised
in DC but where was I born where were
you born in a manger really I did born
in Germany dual citizenship who was
wills favorite rapper as a kid a child
is born with no state of mind blind to
the ways of mankind
melly-mel God smiling on you but he's
frowning too because only God knows what
you go through you grow up in the dead
of little second-rate and your eyes will
sing a song of deep hate the places you
playing where you stay look like
one great big alleyway you admire all
the number book take us looks bit pushes
and the big money make us don't push me
cause I'm close to the it I'm trying not
to lose my hey haha like a jungle
sometimes you make me wonder how I keep
from going under
alright okay which store did Martin
working when he lived in Queens
Victoria's Secret no I worked in with
pepper really do I notice her but we
ever think we never talk never talk
about it what is it
Sears Sears and Wow we were telephone
sales representative just that's
fantastic they be like hello pushes will
work for his father's business when he
was a teenager what job did will carry
out gonna get as far as cigarettes yes
yeah that was definitely wills job his
father cigarette I don't know and doing
his toenails
we did it we installed the freezer cases
in supermarkets okay
what is Martin's well-known catchphrase
Martin has a ton of well-known
catchphrases you know this morning no
I'm trippin what is wills running
catchphrase well you should if we're
gonna be spending time together you
should think about it and I didn't even
know I was doing it but they said I was
putting two oh hell no oh
what does into hell I don't
a says actor-comedian lover where's
their clothes is your bullying Marty mom
your boy I admire in 2005 will was
placed fifth in the blank list in
Hollywood well the it's the the 50
smartest people in Hollywood but this
interview is disproving that but it was
2005 so 15 years ago when his birthday
is
at some point in 2020 April 16th I
actually did know that when it's wills
birthday September 25th Oh kids ever
it's ready fit alright yeah
what is Martin's full name Martin
Ezekiel warrants Joe mom see I'm named
after Martin Luther King and John F
Kennedy oh wow I was born in 65 that
Martin Fitzgerald Lawrence that's fancy
that's a fancy man I don't even know you
love that yeah we know each other
equally
sorry thank you all right just had to
get that out of there we ready to go
actually love that thank you thank you
thank you
that was great thank you very much those
are great you did really those are those
are spectacular